so it looks like
we got some animal activity already hold
on don't come down any further
[Music]
we're here at probably one of the most
beautiful spots that you can see in Big
Bend National Park Santa Elena Canyon
I am Scouting For National Geographic
right now looking for some native
wildlife
you get a lot of Swifts coming through
here there's warblers right now it's the
peregrine falcon migration it's a
birder's paradise
[Music]
being a photographer is all about
putting yourself in position to capture
the best images
sometimes the being there is the hard
part because the access can be extremely
challenging but I have everything I need
I want to see if I can reach some of
these harder to get to areas
we're on our way right now to meet
Ranger Tom Park Rangers not only
understand the layout of the place but
they know exactly the behavior of the
animal that you're trying to find and
exactly where to find it
all right how you doing time to see you
again awesome to see you my friend this
is a really great place actually
probably one of the more productive
areas is along the river and then I
would absolutely stop at muellier's
Overlook in the chisos mountains
appreciate you
[Music]
this is exactly why I love Big Ben
because around every corner is a
completely different landscape we've got
Rivers we've got mountains we've got
desert that brings an Eclectic character
group when it comes to Wildlife but
things like black bears Pumas Bobcats
they're really difficult to see with
your own eyeballs so I've set camera
traps all up and down Big Bend National
Park whenever an animal walks by the
camera takes a photo
it's always like Christmas morning when
you check a trap camera
let's go get some mud on these tires
[Music]
the first time I came to Big Bend we did
it by horseback I've got a lot more
horsepower this time around
pop this long lens on charge some
batteries and then hopefully go and find
some wildlife
so hold on don't come down any further
because we got some animal tracks right
here that's definitely coyote you can
always tell the difference between cat
and dog paw marks because dogs don't
retract their claws when they walk
they're going to come in here to snag
some water and that's why we got the
Trap camera right there
[Music]
set it back up check my frame the only
way to do that is to become the cat
perfect
settling into a circumstance where all
you do is have hope that it's going to
turn out okay and rely on your skill set
your passion and your motivation to get
you through
is where the magic happens oh look at
all these Swifts right now they're all
just over our heads
oh little bird
if I was a swift this is where I would
live the biggest question I get is how
difficult is my job and maybe for
someone else it might be you know one of
the most challenging things you can
think of but I couldn't think of
anything else I would rather do on the
planet it's the easiest job in the world
because it's where my passion drives me
to be is out there in nature chasing
that next Wildlife encounter
thank you
[Music]